This is actually a little paper calculator that I made.
You follow the tube, these split off. These tubes are drectional.
Your first choice is wether you want to choose zero or one.
Which would you like to choose?
Let's choose zero.
So you choose zero, that leads to this instruction to flip.
We flip the page, ...
...continue down.
Plus - you don't choose the operator.
But you do choose the next number...
...that you want to add to zero.
One, let's do Zero plus one.
Zero plus one.
Go here.
Then you just follow the tubes - this is all done automatically.
You follow...
Zero plus one is one.
That's your answer, zero-one is the answer.
Let's do Zero plus Zero.
Zero plus zero, okay.
So you start here, you choose zero.
This tells you to flip.
So theres your zero.
Let's choose to add another zero.
So we'll flip again
So you'll notice, when you flip these flaps,
they can either connect or block off certain pathways later on.
So that's basically how it all works.
You follow...
...these paths...
When you get here, it says to flip.
Then you get to the end.
So...
Your answer is...
zero-zero
Alright, let's do one plus one, Jason.
OK
I've always wanted to know what that is.
What a good thing I've got this calculator here.
I'll go ahead and choose this one.
Leads me to one.
And another one.
That goes to the "equal"-sign.
Tells me to flip.
Tells me to flip again.
And there is our answer.
One-zero.
Or two in binary.
This is basically how calculators and Computers work,
you know, electronic versions of these mazes.
If you'd like to know why on earth Jason was making a calculator out of paper,
you really Need to see what came before
and what's coming next.
Have a look to These extra Videos we're putting on numberphile
either right now or very soon.